c'est l'histoire d'un journaliste en
prison dont les révélations ont changé
le cours des choses à jamais cette année
julian assange fondateur de wikileaks
passera son 50e anniversaire
derrière les barreaux de la prison de
belmarsh à l'est de londres
ces soutiens continue de se mobiliser
pour faire valoir la liberté d'informer
et protester contre une détention jugées
arbitraires et politique pour
sensibiliser le public ils ont lancé la
assange week sur twitter à stella
maurice
la compagne du lanceur dallaire devenu
aujourd'hui l'un de ses relais
médiatiques encourage ses abonnés à
organiser des événements symboliques les
événements locaux sont encouragés vous
n'avez pas besoin d'autorisation aucun
événement n'est trop petit
le but faire prendre conscience que
julian est un prisonnier d'opinion et
célébrer son travail jeunes et gabriel
shipton respectivement père et frère du
journaliste sont actuellement en tournée
aux états unis pour alerter également
sur la situation de julian assange
et si certains n'ont pas pu faire le
déplacement c'est le geste qui compte
le 28 juin reporters sans frontières a
lancé le hashtag happy busday assange
largement relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que l'anniversaire de julian
assange approche je rejoins l'appel free
assange
les charges contre lui devrait être
abandonné et ils devraient être
immédiatement relâchés fait ce que ce
soit son dernier anniversaire derrière
les barreaux le député travailliste
richard burden à adresser lettre au
ministère de la justice au sujet d'un
refus d' entretien vidéo avec julian
assange cher gouverneur nous sommes
profondément préoccupés par votre refus
persistant ainsi que du ministère de la
justice d'autoriser une réunion vidéo en
ligne entre julian assange et un groupe
multi partite de parlementaires
britanniques
cette affaire a des implications
importantes pour la liberté de la presse
vous avez le pouvoir d'accorder une
telle réunion et nous vous demandons de
faciliter une réunion en ligne sans plus
tarder la procédure d'extradition d'un
jeu égal assange devrait reprendre cet
automne dans une interview accordée au
journal l'humanité
c'est là maurice accompagne dit être
inquiète à propos de son état de santé
depuis son arrestation en 2019
il a eu de véritable période de crise
physique et mentale du fait de la
détention et de son quotidien
julian est on
attention depuis deux ans et demi
désormais ses conditions de détention
reste désastreuse en étant incarcéré
dans la prison la plus célèbre du
royaume uni aux côtés des pires
criminels du pays de prisonniers
condamnés pour assassinat de barons de
la drogue
le 4 janvier londres refuse son
extradition vers les etats-unis
l'administration byden fait appel
finalement le président démocrate suit
les pas de donald trump l'administration
byden doit avoir le courage désormais de
mettre un terme à cette saga si le
président des états unis tient
véritablement à la liberté de la presse
et entend protéger le premier amendement
joe biden et son administration ne cesse
de communiquer sur la liberté de la
presse et veulent apparaître sur la
scène internationale comme son plus
fervent défenseur
la détention de julian assange démontre
clairement leur hypocrisie et celle des
occidentaux si julian assange est
extradé vers les états unis il risque
jusqu'à 175 en prison pour avoir diffusé
plus de 700 mille documents
confidentiels sur les activités
militaires et diplomatiques américaine
révélant et des crimes de guerre et
crimes contre l'humanité notamment en
irak et en afghanistan des informations
et qui ont mis à nu les guerres
américaines et qui ont été reprises par
les médias du monde entier